يعني الحياه يا كريمه حبت تكون كريمه معك
تديكي كمان عمري عمري جديد حياتي مدمره
حماتي متدمره حياتي متدمره جدا انا طالعه
ما كنتش
الحمد لله والشكر لله بفضل من ربنا برضو
انا دخلت السجن ما كنتش مريضه انا كنت
مريضه بالغضروف بس ورجليها مكسوره انا
طالعه من السجن في يا جماعه امراض ربنا
وانا انا بحمد ربنا وبشكر فضله على قضائه
الاعتراض ولا لون في حكم ربنا انا بطالب
باي دكتور يتولى حالتي
ويتابع معايا
وبتكلم الساده المشاهدين اللي متابعيني
وسامعيني انا بطالب ان انا اقف على رجلي
عشان اشق طريقي واشوف مصالحي واكل عيالي
بالحلال طيب سيد وهدان اقف على رجلي ونفسي
صحتي ترجع لي زي الاول تاني يا رب يا كريم
سيد وهدان فيها جلطه طيب
تمكنت انت من الصدر